providing and caring for newborn can be
overwhelming at any time
and even more so during a pandemic
that's why one local nonprofit is trying
to ease the stress at least a little bit
for families in need
bianca holman is live with how babies
bounty is helping during this time hi
bianca
hey good morning alex so any parent
knows that diapers
they can be really really expensive and
so babies bounty
they of course provide kits for new
parents and
and everest families but they've had to
switch gears so they
are of course taking and trying to ease
the strength by providing
free diapers and wipes look at all these
amazing wipes
to families in need and to share more
about uh the the diaper bake i'm joined
by kelly so tell us you know how can
people
their need they're seeing this how can
they get plugged in and get some free
diapers
sure so we run a diaper bank uh at our
las vegas location
at 3400 west desert in road every other
tuesday they can register on our website
very easy
every wednesday in henderson so that's
going on today from 10 to two
they can pick up diapers for up to three
children in their family
we supply a week's worth of diapers and
wipes to each family
this is such a stress reliever i can
imagine when they come up and pick up
these
uh packs that you know you can just see
it in their eyes that
you've done some good and that there's a
family that's gonna benefit from this
um so tell me if there are probably some
people who are interested in donating so
if there's somebody who can help
how can people help this effort
absolutely so we do accept
new unopened diapers in the packaging
here at our distribution center at
desert and road
but also cash donations go really far
we're able to purchase
in bulk from the manufacturer so our
dollar goes really far
so if they want to donate on our website
babiesbounty.org
there's a donate button right on the
home page beautiful beautiful so many
families are having to choose
between do i feed my child or do i buy
diapers and they shouldn't have to
choose either
they should be able to just go ahead and
get diapers get the supplies that they
need
get the food that they need and baby's
bounty is doing it so if you are in need
or if you have the ability to help
others
by providing funds or to bring non
new fresh new diapers to bring them here
to their office
babiesbounty.org right that's correct
babiesbounty.org and if you're in
henderson in need of diapers
you got the diaper bait going on there
today starting at what time
10 a.m 10 a.m so again share that with
families
in need if you are a parent yourself and
you need help henderson 10 a.m go to the
website babiesbounty.org
gonna send it back to you guys in the
studio